LEAGUE. AND THERE'S TYRESE
HALIBURTON. ALSO THEY'VE GOT
COLORS GUARDING RUSSELL
WESTBROOK. LEBRON GOOD PASS
INTERIOR RUSS GETS TONIGHT.
RUSS GOES UP DOWN, GOES ROSS
AND HE'S HOT. HE'S HOT IT.
COLLINS. HE'S POINTING
FINGERS. LEBRON, TRYING WHOLE
LOOK AT ROSS. OUCH. YEAH. HE'S
GOT SO WOW. RUNNING DOWN HIS
FOREHEAD. MORE READ. DID NOT
SEE THAT BLOOD UNTIL HE
TURNED. THAT'S NOT GOING TO
STOP EASILY THAT BLEEDING. 99.
92. WELL, THE FIRST ONE HE
TOOK UP WHAT HE GOT A PASS
FROM LEBRON. HE HAS REJECTED,
BUT HE STAYS RIGHT THERE WITH
IT. THEN HE MAKES A HEAD FAKE.
AND WHEN COMING DOWN. CALLERS
HIT HIM ACROSS THE FOREHEAD
WITH THE ELBOW. AND THAT'S
KIND OF WHAT UPSET RUSS
IMMEDIATELY. AND AS ALWAYS,
THEY LOOK AT PLAY'S,
ESPECIALLY WHEN PLAYERS JUMPED
UP AND GO AFTER ANOTHER
PLAYER. AND AS A RESULT OF ALL
THE BLOOD, I WOULD ASSUME THEY
WOULD CALL THIS A FLAKE OR
WHAT. KNEW IT WAS HER DRESS
TOOK EXCEPTION TO IT. THAT'S
ABOUT AS HOT AS ARE GOING TO
SEE HIM GET. AND THEN LEBRON
IMMEDIATELY.